do you struggle with taking notes in an
effective
way at work in this video i'm going to
share the note taking technique that i
developed over the six
years of working at the consulting firm
mckinsey i do believe that note-taking
in an effective way can really make the
difference
for you and your career so please watch
until the end for all the tips that i
have to share here today with you
from all the experiences that i have of
really conducting literally hundreds of
interviews with
clients and internal and external
experts over the time of my career so
welcome everyone to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning and as
you maybe see i got myself
some nice consulting merch so please fix
a nice axle cup if you are interested to
get this stuff as well
check out the merge of crazy management
consultants maybe you have seen my video
about two weeks ago on crazy management
consultant memes they are so hilarious
so i thought that i just get some merch
as well i will leave a link to the
website below in the video description
so check it out but guys let's not talk
about
note taking and i want to start by
sharing a little story that really
happened to me when i was a young
consultant at work we had a project
where we needed to help a client
optimize its working capital so pretty
much optimize its inventory accounts
receivables and accounts payables now we
needed to conduct an interview with the
head of one of the business units of the
company to sit together with them and
collect some ideas and share some
thoughts on what could be done in that
business unit to really improve the
working capital situation so i walked
into that meeting and probably this was
in my first
year of being a consultant and i was
accompanied by a more senior associate
with whom i together conducted the
interview it was a good and long
conversation going on for
almost two hours and i still remember my
blog i had pages over pages of notes
that i had written down they're just
trying to capture
everything pretty much of importance
that was being said so we had this good
conversation and i remember that we
walked back into the team
room and then of course our project lead
was sitting and he was looking at us and
asking so hey
how did it went what did we learn so he
looked at me and i tried to give an
answer but i was so
puzzled and i tried to look through my
notes not to really come up with the
most important points of what was
discussed because in my mind there was
just so much
being said so many information that i
put down but it was really difficult for
me now to on the spot really share the
top ideas the top points that we shared
so seeing how much i struggled the
senior associate was
jumping in trying to help me out and he
just looked at his notes and said
something like so yes we had a good
conversation and there were five
great ideas that we can now implement
really to improve the working capital
one two three four five and then to each
point he was briefly describing what the
idea
was and after seeing this how he handled
that i was just so
astonished how he did this because
clearly he did something completely
different
in the way that he took his notes in the
way that he organized the information
while conducting the interview
it now enabled him to communicate in
this very effective way so later i was
just sitting with him and he had a good
relationship so i just asked him hey can
you just show me what you did there how
did you come up with that how are you
taking your notes so then he showed me
his system and this is pretty much now
the system that i
also took over and refined a bit over
time and this is the system that i will
show you now
in this video but before i talk about
this approach in detail let me give you
the top three reasons why
taking notes in consulting and probably
also many other professional jobs as
well
is very important let me also share what
is specific about that so first
point is the special circumstances that
you are facing when you take these notes
so i did some research before
this video so i looked how other how to
take notes videos on youtube look like
and many of them are about how you can
take these
beautifully looking super well
structured notes
but i trust that this can be great and
effective as well especially for
studying or for taking notes during
university this just
does not work in consulting and indeed
probably most other professional
contexts as well
and the reason is that you are under a
lot of time pressure so you're sitting
in these meetings and of your interview
partner the person that you talk to will
talk pretty fast
and you cannot just constantly ask him
to slow down because you need to
write it more precisely you know you
want to color your notes or anything
like that right this just
will not work and also after the meeting
you will regularly not have the time to
go over all your notes in detail and try
to rewrite them or make them look
good just check out my video on how a
typical work week
of the day of a consultant looks like
again i will link it somewhere above if
you see that i trust you understand
where consultants will not have time to
know in detail rewrite all of them so
bottom line is you need a system where
you can take notes efficiently you do
not have the time to make them look
great
second there is a special expectation in
consulting that especially as a junior
you pretty much
take notes all the time always also if
it's about topics that do not
directly relate to your work stream to
your specific module to your
responsibilities so very often you will
be in a situation where maybe a client
walks into the team room and is having a
conversation with the project lead and
then the client talks about different
things and of course the project lead
tries to engage with them as much as
possible
then very often you will find yourself
in a situation where when the client
left the project lead will look to you
and say
hey heiner you took notes of everything
you said right and then you are like
sitting there um maybe you even feel
like that wasn't even about my work
stream why should i have taken notes
about that so for instance also a team
call
where a partner talks about something
doing something maybe you believe that
probably it's not going to be you
will actually implement it but what if
maybe at the end of the call or maybe
later in a team meeting the project it
asks you if
you can do that specific piece of work
that now the partner talked about
earlier now you will look pretty bad if
you pretty much just have to say um
okay but i didn't take notes can we
please go over it again what exactly i
should do so again situations like this
come up all the time
so pretty much a good advice for young
consultants is to whenever
information of significance are being
shared by partners by your project lead
or by clients doesn't matter whether
they directly relate to your work stream
or not
always take notes and the third thing
that is special about taking notes and
consulting
is that often especially in client
meetings you will try to really take the
notes with pen and paper but not just
with a laptop so i know there are these
great note taking programs like one note
or evernote i use them myself for other
applications as well but especially in
consulting when you sit in front of a
client if you have a laptop in front of
you not typing down
every word that he says often this will
create a big perceived barrier between
you
and the client it will also often make
the whole situation much more formal
than it is maybe the client will close
down
shut down a little bit and will not talk
that openly with you because he feels
like every word that he said
is not taken down on a protocol so for
these reasons it is a common point in
these consulting onboarding trainings
and also the general way of working that
you will try to take
notes pen and paper this will often help
you to communicate with your client in a
much better way and for this reason of
course you need to have a system that
also enables you to take the notes in a
pen and paper format and not only on a
computer but now
let's get tangible how do i do it what
is this note-taking system that i really
refined and also implemented in my daily
job and i prepared here a sheet of paper
that really shows this
stop another autofocus switches so you
see that there are different
sections on this piece of paper so try
to not only just make a long list of
bullet points but
really organize the information now
because i know that's probably pretty
hard to follow just based on this
let me know sketch it for you how
exactly it looks like i will use my pc
for that so let's not go over format how
exactly this could look like so this is
now a big piece of paper and as you see
now you often start
by putting the date when the meeting
took place
in the top left then i often also like
to put the title so what was it about
and then i also like to include a list
of all the participants this is also
important whenever then you write
meeting minutes or any type of protocol
after the meeting that it's often good
practice to also write it down who was
part of the meeting so make sure that
you list everybody down
then a little thing that i really found
useful for myself
it's not necessarily something that i've
seen other people do but what i really
found useful
is to insert a little drawing of the
table and then write the initials of who
was sitting where
and for me this really helped especially
in the beginning of a project
where you have lots of different
meetings and can easily get to know
lots of people in a very short amount of
time for me it was always difficult
after a couple of days to really
remembering so who was who just based on
the names but now with these little
sketches these really helped me to get a
bit of a visual representation
of the table then back into my mind then
knowing ah okay mr so and so was the guy
who was sitting at the end of the table
in this specific meeting so this is just
a little
mind tag that i use to just take me
really remembering who was who
so then you see the upper half of the
paper
this is now kind of the general area the
general note-taking area where just
right have general remarks of what was
being said so this is the part that now
most closely resembles
this general old-school style of just
taking notes one point after the other
and of course if you do
run out of space here then i would just
take a second piece of paper at some
point
exactly just to continue writing down
these bullets as you see here now the
more interesting part is here the lower
part so now in the very bottom quarter
of the page
i often use two sections so to do's for
me to do is for the firm so for our
consulting firm and then to do's for the
client
so in the conversation whenever
something was coming up where either
myself or later as a project lead me or
my team needs to do something
i would directly write it down here not
in the upper part
but then also whenever there was
something where the client confirmed and
committed to do something
i would also write it down here and this
was always great because in the end of
the meeting
then you can do something really
powerful and say okay now let me just
recap what are the next steps and then
you can talk about what you will do now
but then you can also talk about what
the client will do now because otherwise
in a long meeting you often have the
situation that in between you say
okay so this is something that you can
do and then maybe the client agrees
but in the very end probably both of you
have forgotten if you will have them
pages of notes written out
it can be quite tough to really find
these to do points so it's really
helpful to have them in one place
because then you can recap in the end
and you can again ask the client to
commit to these to do's and then of
course also maybe
afterwards you want to write short
meeting minutes and then you already
have this list of to-do's and you do not
need to search them among pages of pages
of notes we are just hidden in the
middle of lots of other texts now next
you're in the middle part of the page
you see an
area where you can really take lots of
value in the situations that i was
describing in the story earlier and this
requires a little bit of preparation
before you walk into the meeting
and this preparation is asking yourself
what do you actually want to get out of
the interview and this is indeed also a
mistake that some more junior
consultants do they just
walk into these client meetings they
walk into these interviews
they're just having a general discussion
about a topic with a client
but without a clear goal in mind what is
your objective what do you want to take
out of the conversation
now coming back to the example of the
working capital reduction project so
what you would be looking for from these
meetings is a list of tangible ideas
that now you hope that the client will
share with you of what could be done to
improve the working capital of the
company and so indeed if you
know before the meeting that this is
what you're looking out for try to make
a section
whenever the client says something that
could be used as an idea that could be
used as a lever in this direction where
you directly write it down because this
now is really powerful whenever
afterwards somebody asks you well what
are you actually taking out of this
conversation you can list exactly these
reasons these
levers these ideas that you collected in
the meeting so now that being said what
you use the bigger part up front where
here you write down all the things that
are neither
to do for you or the client and are also
not directly applicable to this main
objective of the meeting that you have
for instance collecting optimization
ideas so this could be just
other general points of information that
you find worthwhile taking notes that
the client shares pretty much everything
else that somehow seems to be relevant
but you do not want to add into one of
these other buckets that we have below
so trust me if you employ a system like
this for your specific situation as well
you will be far more organized than 99
of most people working outside and doing
these kind of interviews
i hope this was indeed helpful and
valuable and as always if you have any
questions on this topic
leave me a comment below in the comment
section because you know that by leaving
a comment not only will i try to help
you as good as i can
but you are also helping me because
every comment looks good to the youtube
algorithm in addition to that if you
took any value out of this video at all
please smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
my channel to not miss the regular
videos if you want to see even more from
me also follow me on my instagram my
handle is firm learning
and i also have a mailing list you can
find a sign up link to that below in the
video description i now want to say
thank you to all the members of firm
learning you are really making a great
contribution to the channel you're
really
supporting this work so thank you so
much and if anybody of you contemplates
of becoming a member as well you can
just hit the join button next to the
subscribe button where you will learn
about all the details
and yes you will get access to some
member member-only perks so check it out
to see if this might something that
might also interest you now let me end
by saying thank you so much for
everybody who watched until the end i
very much appreciate that as you know i
release a video on this channel every
single saturday so looking
forward to next week to next saturday to
talk about the next topic so until then
bye bye and good weekend to all of you